Barr's Kojo back here on the show good
to see you Boris always good the beer is
now I've known you for damn near 20
years I think right yeah a little longer
actually we met each other at a Jimmy V
golf turn that swears in years and years
ago in North Carolina late 90s what the
hell were you doing then I have your
whole list here I can't keep up with you
anymore well you you're you were doing I
was doing soulful food yes
sofa was my first sort of furry into
this world where I met my wife and now
we're married with two kids it's amazing
my first job on ESPN I met my wife there
too I I saw you guys when you were just
dating playing around for stop the
madness
is amazing and you saw right there the
guy who's playing cupid trying to with
Stuart's right Stuart Scott right in the
middle of all of it and he was
successful well god bless him you know I
know and he's been gone five years now
that's isn't that crazy
that's how did you meet Stu where did
you meet him ah who's that at the gym
Eevee awesome I met him at the gym Eevee
and then I mean when you meet Stuart you
fall in love with him immediately and we
just became fast friends and whenever he
came out to LA we would you know grab
dinner or lunch and you know I met his
daughters and he was just a phenomenal
guy he sure was he is somebody you know
when you think of humanity mm-hm which
in this political climate is like slowly
fading away do you think of somebody
like Stuart he's one of the few men that
I look up to not in terms of what
they've accomplished but just in terms
of what he represents as a man I love
him and and he I miss him every day
I do too I think about a perfect example
what would he have thought of Zion
Williams is not last night oh you don't
mean like existence because we can talk
about obviously who he was a dad and a
father and and a warrior and but I would
have just loved to have heard him mmm
what he would have thought about this
the latest is from from the NBA he might
have made fun of the fact that that the
first three quarters versus this is the
last quarter he would have enjoyed that
yeah I know which we all did and as I
fully admitted not only to you in the
green room but at the very top of the
show I put my kids to bed right around
the middle of the third quarter and had
to catch up on who difference I own
totally unbelievable and well you know
you got to be fair this is he's in in
preseason shape which is completely
normal right
given his injury and and and and how
they're trying to slowly build him up
which is so smart because he's got a
long career ahead of him so to be
careful and mindful about his physical
development and and and you know
adjusting the way he moves in order to
be able to carry that weight that he
carries and the way he plays that's so
explosive I mean what comes to mind or
the player comes to mind to me hmm who
had that kind of physical skill was
Shawn Kemp he was another guy who was
literally flying but I think Zion is
probably heavier than all I think so
Kemp was even though it was 610 cameras
of rock yeah you know anything like he
was chiseled and so it's almost like if
Shawn Kemp and Charles Barkley had a
baby but I'm so excited for him I'm
excited to watch him these next these
next year's it's just something that
we've never seen before but it's
interesting that you bring up wait you
know we have a still of a moment in the
game from last night where he's sitting
on the bench and ESPN put as they say on
the bottom of the screen the lower third
there it is 285 pounds third heaviest
player in NBA this season
that is that's me and a and a 70 pound
weights got to my back
that's crazy could you imagine if people
in your industry were we're measured
that way just that well zoom in on you
like an award show something like that
the con are the way that we're
scrutinized on camera is it's pretty
similar actually but I mean even though
even though our weight has nothing to do
with direct without performance but
still so what do you think he needs did
you can't play a 285 right I mean don't
you think he's got what we gotta get his
own benefit I wish he would be 240 look
he's not sitting around you know you
know with hanging out with smoothie king
well you know what you know what it is I
think that we all have certain habits
that have been established by our
parents and media environment so the way
he eats is it's it's a habit so I think
that it takes a while for him to replace
those paradigms with a new sense of okay
responsibility and accountability and
say okay if I want to have a long career
if I want to have a 18 year career yes I
have to subscribe to a certain way of
living that not just feels my my my
performance but also extends my my years
on the court he's also what 12 years old
how old is exactly he's twelve fishel
e19 a little bit I grew until I was 12 I
grew two inches in college so he could
still grow he could still grow two
inches I mean you know I hope he has a
great you know mentor down there in New
Orleans somebody who was in his ear
about you know working towards the long
career and who could it be it could be a
now I'm serious they could be brief I
mean why would I not look at some guy
who's 40 yeah at some point Brees at
some point Brady Brady went through
Boris Kodjoe here in the Rich Eisen show
he went through the something that you
just described at some point realize you
know I gotta start eating I gotta start
living I gotta start doing everything
24/7 365 no cheat days cheat days might
be an extra scoop of avocado ice cream
you know
being what we're talking about but he
still just he's 19 he's on ESPN last
night Twitter exploded in every which
way possible that in the first three
quarters he's out of shape he's not
healthy he's limping around if he does
have sort of that run around like he's
he's looking at jogging
I mean look with a limp I didn't know
what I was doing in my 20s I had no idea
about anything in my time I could barely
tie my shoes he's 19 he's playing in the
league I mean he's not supposed to know
all of these things great and he's has
he has so many people in his ear right
now he has to first decipher which one
of those voices he wants to keep around
in which which which which people he
needs to step away from right that's a
whole process in itself you know who do
you listen to
who do you surround yourself with a lot
of people have great loyalty with their
friends from high school not the best
thing sometimes so you have to figure
out what is your journey and slowly sort
of get on that path and I man III wish
him all the best I hope he's gonna be
around for a long time 17 straight
points though in corner right
unbelievable it was exciting just really
exciting and obviously the folks in New
Orleans are very excited we've got right
here on the Rich Eisen show from ABC
station 19 season 3 premieres tonight
two hours on eight Eastern on ABC we'll
talk about that a little bit more at
Boris Kodjoe on the Rich Eisen show so
who do you think we you got a feel the
Lakers with LeBron and AD there are your
favorites based on what we've seen so
far I'm of the belief that bored man
when he gets to the playoffs with Paul
George and Doc and the rest of this team
that still is figuring its way out when
when people are not healthy and when
they're healthy we're still figuring
their way out then when it comes down to
it that Kawhi has been the king of the
post season as we've seen now for just
last year and obviously in years before
I I'm still I'm still not sleeping on
the Clippers just because the Laker town
supposedly not at all especially you
know he bored man I think he he's done a
great job load managing right which
people give him a lot of crap for mm-hmm
I think
that's what it comes down to in the end
I love the fact that this year we have
true parity for the first time in a long
time I don't even I can't even remember
the last time nobody knew what was gonna
happen right
I love the Bucs I love the the Celtics I
love Miami came out of nowhere a bunch
of young players doing great things yeah
I mean if the same record is the Jazz
right now 31 and 13 there I think second
in the east
uh-huh Philly I've not given up on
Philly especially when I'm beat comes
back and then the West is stacked from
top to bottom I mean I gave I give the
Lakers a little bit of an edge but other
than that nobody knows what's going to
happen even even Houston with the two
young guns I love this season and I
cannot wait to get to the playoffs
because of that very reason
and he honesty honest to the whole
concept of they need to win this year
for him to want to stick around in
Milwaukee
you know before he's he's he's like me
he's European African so it's a
different culture in plays the different
metallic me through that what do you
know there's a great sense of comfort
and happiness cannot be measured in
superlatives mmm once you're comfortable
and happy what else do you want right so
if he is comfortable and happy in
Milwaukee yes which was his first
experience coming to the States he has
build an environment he has that that is
conducive to him succeeding he has his
loved ones around him he loves the
community I would not bet against him
staying there so you were saying where
he's look at dick huh dick is another
example of that
dick Nowitzki mm-hmm right also from
Germany and and he was never tempted to
leave he's got he had a million options
to go anywhere after his first two deals
he never wanted to go anywhere because
he felt comfortable his family was there
he had built an environment a community
around him that was that was that was
feeding him and he'd never wanted to
leave
so you're saying because of the European
[Music]
yes don't use the usual conventional
wisdom of player wants to go to a let
see spa I know I know country is all
about always being the best and always
maximizing your potential sometimes
people just want to be who they are
where they are and if they're
comfortable and happy then why why push
them to go somewhere else
bigger market well so so what we can't
measure happiness in those kind of terms
all the time doesn't work yeah and the
right by the way it works to thirty nine
and six being the records right so he go
they've won 86% of their games
it's amazing it's amazing
Boris Kodjoe here in the Rich Eisen show
alright let's talk about station
nineteen your as you referred to
shondaland shonda rhimes who is very
successful whatever it wants to put her
mind or append to what's it like being a
meeting with her oh she's she's super
smart she's she's funny and she loves
what she does mm-hm and that makes all
the difference right so she has a she
has true integrity and purpose when it
comes to her craft which is writing and
so she doesn't compromise on that what
is she what is she plugged into that
this country wants in television I mean
again it Grey's Anatomy private practice
scandal yeah I mean that's just for
right you know what I think I think it's
I think its authenticity
I think it's representation which we've
always been challenged with here um to
realize that you know this world is not
white right and therefore we need to
represent on television what the world
really looks like how people really
speak how to relate to each other
and do that in a relevant in a current
way and she's she she has her finger on
the pulse of that and she's actually
established at it over the past ten
years or so right so again being being
being a part of her ecosystems is a true
and it's been a lot of fun every set is
is like a family affair
they don't accept ask which is which is
so refreshing which is so great
one who one ask can ruin it for
everybody and a lot of people in his
business unfortunately you know who
don't have the Constitution yes they
they need to compensate for the
insecurities and they become ass right
and money and fame just amplifies who
you were before so unfortunately
sometimes there's a few bad apples who
make it bad for everybody else and she
doesn't she doesn't she doesn't mess
with that and you play Captain Robert
Sullivan what have you learned about
first responders firefighters three or
three seasons of dividers are amazing
they put their lives on the line every
single day for the greater purpose I
mean watch what happen in Australia in
the past couple of weeks right once my
gosh the firefighters from all over the
world came in and helped and and to be
able to represent them I learned a lot
about you know the physical challenges
of carrying all this gear around all the
time and and and being in a fire is
scary' y'all it's really scary because
you cannot eat have you ever been in a
steam room that was so hot that you
couldn't really stand out for sure
that's exactly how it is times ten right
right so even with all that gear the
heat is unimaginable and sometimes you
literally on all fours crawling through
these spaces because it's too hot to
stand up too hot to breathe your lungs
it's I can't I can go on and on
to just to and to be able to represent
that and do it in a most authentic way
possible is I'm very lucky
yeah against station 19 against season 3
premieres tonight on ABC at 8:00 Eastern
Time tell me about Co fit love my
brother Patrick who is a certified
trainer life coach and a nutritionist
develop this with me it's a family
fitness app no because what we figured
out is that a lot of people have a
challenge staying fit and healthy is
because they say don't have enough time
they can't go to
Jim they don't have any equipment so we
came up with a way for the whole family
to engage in establishing some healthy
habits one bite-size at a time you don't
need an hour and a half in a gym every
day all you need is 5-10 minutes a day
to establish some of these positive
patterns right then help you become more
healthy whether it's working out or
meditation or nutrition we're talking
about diet we don't we don't like
rigorous diets because they're not
sustainable if you like ice cream like
me you're not gonna stop eating ice
cream come on what ice cream are you
eating I love ice cream like okay like
seriously
haagen-dazs and Ben and Jerry's okay
should we doughnut cookie what is it
called you don't look like honest with
you
you must be dude team Kofi calm must be
doing very well to get this app it's
true must be doing everything in measure
rich everything in measure you can't
overdose an ice cream of course but you
got it you know everything has to be in
moderation
did I see Terry Crews in that video we
got friends stopping by it's a family
affair you know when you work out even
five or ten minutes a day you do it with
the family it's sustainable it's fun yes
you create some healthy habits for your
children yes will become more and more
sedative sitting on the couch on their
devices now in the video we took his
shirt off was that scripted or is that
unscripted not you cannot script
anything for Terry Nikki sure he does
what Terry wants to do it which is great
hey man thanks for coming on they were
welcome any time as you know that I
appreciate and you know it's funny when
just to bring this all full circle when
we talk Stewart at the very beginning
you know you know when he first met you
okay
and and we just saw there was a great
oral history of Stewart of people who
have met Stewart and known Stewart that
was in the ringer I don't know if you
saw that it was great and he just never
thought he was better than you okay he
basically just wanted to whenever resize
he was competitive out everything you
know he only thought he could have done
your job as an actor better than you of
course
oh no and that is given the chance yeah
to be a movie star a television star an
actor deep down oh yeah he he thought he
would have won an Oscar given that
chance
that's one
right absolutely how did he ever say
that to you he wasn't pulling your
punches he would always ask you a
question that seemed really topical what
do you mean but it was really hidden
criticism you know what I mean walk me
through that he would he would he would
say so when you um in in brown sugar
when you were doing the impromptu to the
rap that you were doing there with mos
def was that was that it did you write
that before
did you basically he's telling me that
he wouldn't have written it he would
have just done it off the top of his
dome yeah so he would ask a question it
was really loaded yeah and then you
ended up walking away from the
conversation feeling bad yeah and he
felt empowered it's yes I was through
interesting enough he would write down
all of his catchphrases he shot sheets
including booyah movie yeah cuz I knew
that be oo - y ou W is how he would
spell it on his shot sheets because
that's what he would do
well see yes I knew it I knew it yeah
yes sir that is Stewart may he rest in
peace incredible love that guy good to
see you Boris at Boris Kodjoe on both
Twitter and Instagram and of course
check out station 19 tonight 8:00
Eastern on ABC and gives Suzy a kiss for
me yes same to Nicole for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app